[Music]
hey
we're back once again you still have you
still have your volume on i can hear it
i can't
stop it it's
so distracting well it's like it's
distracting like trying to talk and then
like hearing something else in my other
ear
see you know what i'm saying yeah i
couldn't hear
well i couldn't hear it i'm not
sensitive you must be deafer than i am
even though i'm pretty damn deaf
who comes right now hi pokey what are
you doing uh-oh uh oh she's gonna come
up don't jump up here please don't jump
up here
like you can go over there and sit but
please don't like sit up so
last night was pretty good show yeah we
had a good time i can't believe it went
on for almost five hours a good thing i
guess it's a good thing that we didn't
do the
ten cases like i was originally gonna do
yeah we'd have been here all night
you always do that [ __ ] well because i
thought i was because i thought the
cases were
like not well shorter than they were but
then like when i went back through and
like
you know read through them i was like
nah i guess we can get enough material
i'll stretch that [ __ ] out [ __ ] it
that's true he'll just like three times
three times and then he gets on my case
for like not ending the show like oh you
take too long to end it even though she
even though he's the one that's like
that's making the show go on no i'm not
making normally
she's trying to blame me
[Laughter]
she's trying to attack pitchers and [ __ ]
well like i said i think because one of
her
one of her christmas presents is in one
of those boxes
yeah and she could be and she can
probably smell it well i got her some
new
all right i got her some new minties
looks like everybody's in there
because she loves those little minty
toys everybody's in a chat
she likes to rub them on her face but
she you know i get beijing likes them
too so i
so i buy them from chewie and then they
like them so much that they get like
really really dirty
like really quickly because they pick
them up in one hand and they're like ah
and they're like eating it stuff and
then like you find it later it's all
like grubby looking
badger says that he's got a greatest
paranormal investigation show is called
um paranormal porn star i would watch
that not gonna lie
what channel is that on i mean
starring belladonna
that's still my favorite porn movie
title of all time
[Laughter]
we are talking about now somebody
actually recommended that we watch this
i
knew we would probably get around to it
eventually because you know it's netflix
and
it's a new horror movie that they added
this is called ghosts of war from 2020.
yeah now it's weird because okay so this
was directed by the same
guy uh eric bress that directed the
butterfly effect
but that movie didn't come out that came
out like back in 2004. i remember that
and i guess this was yeah that wasn't a
bad movie um what
was that no no 2000 butterfly effect oh
wait i'm getting confused
yeah what do you thought there was a
butterfly effect back from the 90s
um i don't think there's another one
this one came out and i'm pretty sure
this came out in 2004
the butterfly effect well i think ashton
kutcher was in if i'm thinking of the
right one like i remember it being like
a pretty decent movie
because i thought there was a butterfly
effect one about a mailman who comes
back
from um uh vietnam war
and then he's having these flashbacks
about something that happened in korea
and then
he's seeing freaky freaky [ __ ] and then
it turns out he was part of that
[ __ ] um cia experiment with all the
hallucinogens i think it was called
butterfly effect
you sure you're not thinking of jacob's
ladder it might have been jacob's ladder
that's what i'm thinking of jacob's
ladder
yeah that's a yeah totally different i
don't know why
i thought that jacob's ladder came out
in the 90s yeah and they did a remake of
it last year which was
yeah okay but not great yeah i mean you
know
but this one okay so let's so that guy
hadn't actually directed a movie since
2004. i think he did write a couple of
the final destination movies which are
also kind of a lot of fun
um because of all the creative deaths
and everything but i guess this is the
first movie he directed since then
now it's interesting because like when
we were watching this movie
like i really dug this movie yeah it was
a good movie um
but then like when i went and read the
reviews it's really weird because it
seemed like
most of the like general critics that
just kind of like review everything
like pretty much liked it but the horror
specific
people hated it [ __ ] them and and i'm
not really sure why it's like here's the
thing i don't okay
so this is a new movie so i don't want
to spoil it
it's hard to talk about without spoiling
it
but i think that that's why because if
you are not
on board with this because near the end
of the movie this takes a
a hard left turn and like doesn't um
it has like a big huge twist ending and
if you don't like that twist ending
then it this is gonna piss you off
here's the setup
this small team of us soldiers
in world war ii they're in france
fighting the germans
and uh they get they get stationed at to
take over this little outpost
and when they get there it's like a it
turns out it's a haunted house
yeah and they do an investigation it's
just like a big manor house big
big mansion yeah now while i'm watching
it i was enjoying it
the edit was good it was it was moving
right along the acting was good
i was looking at it and i was going
there's some not quite right with those
uniforms they're supposed to be 82nd
but on their helmets they have they have
kind of like the regimental
insignia from the 101st yeah someone i
saw someone else commenting on
another review of it didn't notice the
same thing yeah they're in
they're in 82nd airborne uniforms
in terms of the patches on the uniform
but you looked at the helmet it said
that was uh the symbol of [ __ ] i
think the
506 or maybe like the 5.0 deuce which is
a spade
i think it was fivo deuce at that time i
don't remember
because i think 327 was clubs anyway i'm
going like that's the wrong
that's the wrong [ __ ] helmet and then
there were also things that cut you know
because
i'm kind of an [ __ ] when it comes to
kind of [ __ ] have kind of a stick no
no wait a minute wait a minute they're
still in france which means they haven't
been there long
yeah because it was 1944 like they said
at the beginning yeah and the 82nd was
issued
elbow knee pads and where were their
[ __ ] knee pads
most of them you know what i mean and
they also were issued
a uniform that was kind of like a very
early od
green bdu style uniform they weren't
wearing that they were wearing just
regular dress shirt
pants and it was almost kind of like the
only thing they were missing was the tie
kind of like their class b
uniform it wasn't really the combat
uniform for that time
and then later on they start saying some
things with your anachronistic
one of the dudes is [ __ ] lying
telling this war story about hitler
youth that he killed
well they just got there he's just in
france he hasn't been to germany yet or
no hitler youth in france what the
[ __ ] he talking about
so i was kind of dinging the movie on
all this [ __ ] because it's like this
seems like you're like you're seeing
an acronym well and one thing i noticed
too i'm not sure if you can
but about [ __ ] quantum fit he talks
about quantum entanglement
yeah there's no quantum entanglement in
the 40s but
one thing i don't i don't know if you
noticed this or not but one of the
characters was talking about his
favorite werewolf movies and the second
one he mentioned was i was a teenage
werewolf oh that's 50s
which didn't come out till the 1950s
yeah um
but it's explained later on yeah so it's
like
you know like i said i don't really want
to spoil it too much but how you feel
about this movie is gonna have a lot to
do with how you feel about
the twist ending because i feel like a
lot of like the horror guys that i
watched like really really
did not [ __ ] with that twist ending they
just really did not like it
um i was not bothered by it at all um
and honestly like up until then i
thought
it's really weird because the house
where they shot this i'm not sure where
it is but it kind of the inside of it
kind of reminded me of the place
where they shot like a haunting of hill
house like it looked very similar
like with that big you know open space
with like the big staircase and [ __ ]
um i don't think it's the same one but
it looked like that
and up until then like i really really
liked the way that was show
it's not you know the haunted house part
of it
is not like real original like the
ghosts kind of like
you know look the same and it's
basically like there was uh i guess the
ghost story behind it is like there was
a french family they lived that they
were hiding some jews and like the nazis
came and like did all this horrible
stuff to the family
and they're the ghosts that have been
haunting the [ __ ] so it's like kind of
this mystery they're trying to figure
that out
but that's not really um you know i
thought that was like really well done
but it's not like a super original it's
just like a pretty generic like haunted
house story i think the strength
of the movie is the characters
and like the interaction between the
characters i recognized like a bunch of
the actors uh the one guy that was in it
i can't remember what his character's
name was but it was the same guy that
played
shades on luke cage right yeah
um and i think the main actor he was on
some like dc
dc universe show titans or so i don't
remember what the [ __ ] he was on
but all of the all of the actors in here
looked like familiar you know what i
mean
from different series and i really liked
the rapport they had with each other and
i liked that they were
distinct characters but they didn't get
bogged down like in a lot of exposition
or anything like that they just seem to
have like an easy camaraderie like they
would um also uh good gore effects in
this and i think it was
i think it was all practically done at
least the gore was like you know was
seeing
you know limbs getting blown off and
[ __ ] like that they'll all like look
really good
um and i really liked the you know the
art direction like the interior and the
inside of the
house and everything i love that i love
that um
like that blue green kind of thing and
then it's got like
you know bits of red and like yellow and
stuff like that i think that looks
really super cool it's a good movie you
just don't want to know much going into
it just don't just just
just just watch it yeah because i didn't
want to haunted house movie because i
didn't know that it was going to
have a big twist ending right but
when that happened i was just kind of
like oh yeah
it's explained and this definitely seems
i can see how if you're not
on board with the twist and you know
people just be like oh [ __ ] that you
know what i mean like i can see that but
i didn't have that reaction it's hinting
at time
loops and [ __ ] too you know yes it's hit
but it all works out in the end of the
movie you gotta go okay that's why
and i do feel like this is one that i
think would even would be even better
like if you watched it a second time
because then you would like pick up all
the clues
because there was definitely like clues
that were sprinkled throughout the movie
about like what was really going on
so somebody else noticed to the [ __ ]
the the the uh yeah like i was with the
uniforms
i was reading um [ __ ] that was like like
a bunch of horror
uh channels like covered this because
like i said it's netflix so you know
everybody all the horror channels are
gonna cover it
i can't remember which one it was um
maybe it was blood bath and beyond or
something like that but somebody in the
comments like did say something about
yeah i started noticing that
u.s had two [ __ ] airborne divisions
the 82nd and 101st they were kind of
sister divisions
but the the the 101st which i was in
at that time was a glider unit uh
instead of parachute units
and the motif for the division to even
to this day
is gambling everything is the the
the the the houses of cards and dice
yeah so all your units all their all
their symbology
is about gambling so you know you see
all these [ __ ] hokey ass movies with
guys with spades on their helmets like
that's that is only [ __ ] one regiment
inside the 101st yeah because there's
also clubs diamonds and hearts
and then there's dice usually the unit
patches in the cymbals if it's 506 it's
the sh it's the
five on the die a zero with the [ __ ]
dice showing six
so there's all our numbers are all
hidden in these pictures
it's pretty cool the idea was to just to
confuse the [ __ ] out of the enemy how
many of them are there
there isn't 506 [ __ ] regiments you
know what i mean
yeah there isn't 101 divisions
you just the numbers are all random
numbers to make the army seem much
bigger than it is
well don't tell everybody now that you
believe oh that's old that's old
just kidding they were doing that [ __ ]
they were doing that [ __ ] in the
american civil war
yeah [ __ ] yeah it's part of the old
camouflage
you find you capture paperwork from the
enemy and they're talking about the 88
division and the 82nd division and this
well [ __ ] how many divisions are there
well there might only be 20. but it
sounds like there's [ __ ] 500 of them
you know
but that's just the game well yeah you
know yeah
um yeah somebody said that one of the
guys in this movie brent uh brenton
thwaites was in the signal which
actually i
don't think we ever reviewed that but
that actually is like a really decent
movie i think you can watch him you
might be able to watch it on tubie
i think that's where i watched it now
fourth throwdown said yeah it's a good
movie but the twist went a little too
far for me
like i get that i get that because it
really does
kind of come out of nowhere because i
was like for a second i was just kind of
like wait what you know what i mean
but once i kind of got into it and then
they kind of explained
like what was going on and um like i
said i really really don't want to spoil
it and it's really really hard to talk
about without spoiling it
but um i it didn't bother me like one
yes it was very it was jarring like at
first because i'm like wait what the
[ __ ] is going on suddenly
but then like once you like listen to
everyone's dialogue and like once they
like explained it and everything
um you know they it definitely did make
a lot of sense and like i said it made
me want to watch it a second
time oh also billy zane is in this yeah
that's right i didn't expect him
he looks like a good a lot of good
firefight scenes world war ii firefight
scenes but they're moving awful fast and
they're awful
[ __ ] a lot of luck involved in them
but it's all explained
in the end yeah yeah so you know i think
they did a really good job with this
like i said i really liked
you know the creepy haunted house [ __ ]
at the beginning and then like after the
twist when it goes like in a totally
different direction yeah um i think
i don't know i i actually really liked
it and i was like actually really
surprised
by the negative reviews like i said it
seemed like a lot of the negative
reviews were mostly coming from like the
hardcore horror dudes
it's a lot like jacob's ladder it's one
of those kind of twists in a way
yeah because at one point uh one of the
characters like in the first like three
quarters of the movie
references the ambrose beer story and
occurrence at owl queen
owl owl creek owl creek bridge i always
say like that
um so if you know that story you might
kind of get an
idea of not exactly what the twist is
but you know you kind of get an idea of
like what
is going on kind of which i've used you
know jacob's ladder i guess you could
kind of say the same thing because
an occurrence at owl creek bridge was
um i i don't know if it was the first
story to use that trope
where you know obviously i'm just you
know i'm not worried about spoiling
jacob's ladder because that came out
back in the 90s
but that trope where you know everything
that happens in the movie is just like
the last
thoughts of somebody that's dying or
whatever um so
i so maybe that ambrose beer story was
the first one to do that but it's
certainly one of the most famous ones
because i remember reading it in school
and uh we watched the there was like a
movie made of it was not like a
feature-length movie it's a short film
but uh yeah so somebody references that
in this
too so that's like i said another kind
of clue but like i said it's not that's
not
exactly what's going on but yeah sort of
um but yeah so i guess it's sunday and
we're kind of tired
young pokey's over here biting at
pookie's biting and she was biting
was she biting the chair bite my hand oh
she's playing your head yeah
yeah she was uh she tried to get me to
play joke and bite she's like come on
daddy no she just like
bites very softly all right so uh we
will be back again tomorrow same
bat time same bat channel talking about
another movie which you've actually
already watched
but i'm not gonna spoil it it's gonna be
a surprise i like that
so uh yeah thanks you guys for stopping
by and we'll see you guys again tomorrow
bye